The joe rogan experience.
It's amazing how many Kim Kardashian
clones exists now. I mean,
and even in her own family,
I don't know all the names of them,
but one of the younger ones she,
it's like she went to the
plastic surgeon and she was like,
I want to look like Kim,
and they just give her the same face.
What the fuck is up with them?
The thing is the most disgusting thing
where they're taking fat stuff and an
into their ass and they
developed this diaper,
but I mean there's a lot of people
out there with diaper button.
I met a girl the other
day that had diaper,
but she was at the comedy store and
I couldn't look away. I was like,
what is happening to her? But because I
knew it wasn't real. I knew she had. Okay,
spindly legs. Yeah, the skinny
legs and then the, well girl,
if a girl has a big like hips and
the right are art crumb comics.
Do you remember our chrome comics
now our comments are chrome.
There was a great documentary called
crumb and it's about this guy who was just
like really eccentric perverted cartoonist
from the 1970s and he would always
draw these women with these
enormous legs and enormous, but,
but they weren't fat. They
were just voluptuous. They
will know it was. You got to,
it's past voluptuous into
like super athlete DNA.
Like if you could get that girl,
make some male babies with it,
you would have a fucking
ultimate warrior like that.
See that woman like they are perfect.
How to have fun with a strong girl.
And you see our chrome, that's actually
him. Ronnie Coleman legs. Yeah.
That's actually him with his boner. Cause
he was as a really frail, Dorky guy.
And he's got this image of this
woman who just looks like a tank.
She says he's giant muscle legs and,
and big boobs,
but not like ridiculous stripper boobs,
but more like just Super Alpha Dna.
Female boobs.
Yeah. He was a freaky guy. Like, look
at him. He's got soccer. I mean that's,
that's who he was. Like who
they want above that, Jamie,
the one to the right. Yeah,
right. They're like, oh my
goodness, is what he used to draw.
He was always drawing this enormous,
powerful women.
This guy was definitely into
getting dominated. Oh yeah.
He would just shove his whole head
and their pussy or something. Sure.
Like look at him.
He had him riding one.
I guess he's supposed to be having sex
with her and this guy definitely noted in
like two seconds. Yeah. Oh man,
look, he's choking them in these car.
Like he's always choking them.
Like you literally couldn't have an art
crumb today that looks like it looks
kind of like a woody Allen
too. Oh yeah, sure. Yeah.
Well see if you could find a
video of him are crumb. Uh,
the documentary is fascinating because
I think he wound up moving to France or
something like that. I think
you want to leaving America. Um,
but there's, there's actually,
if you go to video, you'll,
you'll find there's video of him.
But that was the guy.
He's a really fascinating guy.
That's not him.
It looks just like him on the
right. Not In the right. Oh,
that's not definitely not the right guy.
He wants him on the left. Does that him?
Um, oh, there it is. Oh
yeah. He just looks odd.
It just cause you just holding up that
picture and maybe it's also because I'm
looking at him now as an older man.
Um,
the lot of the video
that I'd seen was him.
It bothers me to look at him and think
like, that guy has a strong sex drive.
Like, oh, that's the, yeah, he might not,
he might just save it up for every couple
of weeks and they draw one of those
cartoons and beat off to it or
find a cow suitable. Exactly.
Pay Somebody to sit on his face. A
strange, strange character though.
It doesn't matter Jamie.
It's all good. What's up?
I'll say it looks like he
did Fritz the cat too. Yeah.
Yeah, he did. Fritz the cat,
he did a lot of a pretty famous, uh, uh,
animated or cartoon
comic book Type Things,
but they were all at cartoonish
features. Everybody was weird. Yeah.
And you think Kim has now made that,
that that's the no, but that standards,
this is like a real, like that those
women's acids that are crumb drew,
I'm not justifying his stuff,
but they were freak gene DNA specimen,
like those women at giant thighs and
giant acids and that's who they were.
Whereas with Kim, she's got
those spindly not, yeah,
like her bud is this digital,
it's a surgical creation.
Like there's pictures of her that
are online that make it look good,
but they're all photo shopped.
And we found out about that because she
got Paparazzi when she was in Mexico.
They caught her on the beach and that
was the one that they were showing right
there on that way. It gets
worse than that way. Grocer,
they caught her wandering around the
beach and they took photos of her,
like real Paparazzi photos.
She would have fake Paparazzi photos
where she would hire Paparazzi,
take photos of her,
and then she would Photoshop a mob and
they made it look like everything was in
place. But it's not, yeah,
it's, it's a disaster.
This is what it really looks like.
Yeah. Yeah. So is that it? Okay.
So if the legs match the ass, I'd,
I'd be totally fine with that.
But even that acid is a distortion.
There's so much going
on there because you,
you're not supposed to have
that much fat in one place.
It was a girl has an ass like that has
legs to match it. That's what I'm saying.
If the legs match the ass,
I like it. But the legs,
the legs throw it off cause little,
little twig legs and then you got the S.
It's just not just a larger message.
It's like those guys that shoot
synthol until the muscles muscles,
it's the same thing. Like you're
not, that's not a real ass.
Like I know they'll synthol
muscles are not real moms there.
So obviously fake, but yeah, cause the
legs don't bend the legs mashed it.
I'd be like, that's nice. Yeah. But it
wouldn't match it. It's just not possible.
And I've seen some where
somewhere matches. Yeah, but
not like that. It's just,
it's the whole thing is a disaster. It's
just, have you ever watched the poor guy,
his face. He's like, I'm
nailing this shit. Yeah, I got
this shit on lock. Oh my God,
this guy, he does. I mean,
these guys wind up getting
horrible infections too.
Sometimes they've, they, well,
this gang green and shit, they say that
there's an actual thing. Oh my God.
You say ha. You see, they say how
there's an actual thing called bigorexia.
Like there's Anorexia and there's bigger
X. Body dysmorphia is exists with a,
I mean,
there's,
there's people that have body dysmorphia
in terms of their facial features.
They just can't stop tweaking their nose.
Okay.